over the prior week
and the seven-day average of daily
deaths are about 1600 per day which is
an increase of about 40 percent over the
previous week
over the past several weeks we have seen
the number of daily cases increased
substantially the magnitude of this
increase is largely related to the
omicron variant which now represents
about 98
of the cova 19 cases in the country
we continue to learn more about omicron
with each passing day including the
severity of disease caused by this
variant
just yesterday a pre-print study of
daser from data from kaiser permanente
southern california analyzed by academic
partners with cdc collaboration and
funding provided key insight into
clinical outcomes among patients
infected with the omicron variant
this study used mathematical modeling to
estimate risk of hospitalization and
severe disease from a health care system
that provides care to 4.7 million people
in southern california 19 percent of the
state's total population and noted
substantially reduced risk of severe
clinical outcomes in patients who are
infected with the omicron variant
compared with delta
in the study there were over 52 000
cases of omicron compared with nearly 17
000 cases of delta
displayed on this slide are figures from
this study
on these graphs green represents
infections with the omicron variant and
purple represents infections with the
delta variant
when compared to delta infections with
omicron were associated with a 53
reduction in adjusted risk of
symptomatic hospitalization displayed in
the first panel
a 74 reduction in adjusted risk of icu
admission displayed in the middle panel
and a 91 reduction in adjusted risk of
mortality displayed on the third panel
no patients with omicron required
mechanical ventilation
additionally the study found that those
infected with omicron who were
hospitalized had a shorter duration of
hospital stay compared those with delta
the duration of hospital stays was
approximately 70 percent shorter with
the median of stays being 1.5 days for
omicron compared to about five days for
delta
looking at all hospital admissions for
omicron 90 of patients were expected to
be discharged from the hospital in three
days or less
this study controlled for important key
parameters such as age
sex
prior sars cov2 infection prior
vaccination and comorbidities
the data in this study remain consistent
with what we are seeing from omicron in
other countries including south africa
and the uk and provide some
understanding of what we can expect over
the coming weeks as cases are predicted
to peak in this country
while we are seeing early evidence that
omicron is less severe than delta and
that those infected are less likely to
require hospitalization it's important
to note that omicron continues to be
much more transmissible than delta
the sudden and steep rise in cases due
to omicron is resulting in unprecedented
daily case counts
sickness
absenteeism and strains on our health
care system
the risk of hospitalization remains low
especially among people who are up to
date on their covid vaccines
however the staggering rise in cases
over one million new cases each day has
led to a high number of total
hospitalizations
as we see hospitals and health systems
caring for more and more patients in the
midst of staffing challenges and faced
with a highly transmissible virus that
does not spare our health care workers
we must do all of us do our part to
protect our hospitals and our neighbors
and reduce the further spread of this
virus
as you've heard me say before we know
what works against cover 19. this means
getting vaccinated and getting boosted
wearing a mask in public indoor settings
in areas of high transmission and
currently that's over 99 of our counties
and testing before you gather with
others
thank you i'll now turn things back over
to you jeff thanks dr woliske before i
turn to dr fauci
for an update on kobe treatments i want
to emphasize that we have more courses
of effective treatments now
than at any other point during the
pandemic
this is the direct result of the biden
administration's focus from day one
to stock our nation's medicine cabinet
with a diverse set of treatments
and the aggressive actions we have taken
to expedite research development
manufacturing and procurement
today i want to provide some context
specifically about actions the biden
administration took on pfizer's
antiviral pills
last spring the company and the
administration agreed to work together
to speed up both clinical research and
manufacturing timelines
originally the company had projected
that clinical trials would not conclude
until the middle of this year 2022.
in cutting red tape and sourcing key
supplies the government and pfizer
collaborated to dramatically accelerate
the clinical trial process
shaving about seven months from the
original timeline
so instead of waiting for clinical trial
results in mid-2022
we got those results late last year
and we were able to begin shipping the
first pills in december
months ahead of schedule
at the president's direction we also
acted early and aggressively to secure
significant supply of pfizer's antiviral
pills
the u.s has now purchased 20 million
treatment courses
working closely with pfizer we're
further accelerating the delivery of
these bills so we'll have the first 10
million by the end of june
instead of the end of september
and we continue to work with pfizer to
help them further expand their
manufacturing capacity
including through the defense production
act if needed
as dr fauci will discuss these pills are
meant for those at high risk of severe
disease from covid
we have a number of other treatment
options that work against omicron
and we're working to increase our supply
of those treatments as well
just this week we completed the purchase
of another six hundred thousand
treatment courses
of glass glaxosmithkline's monoclonal
antibody treatment
that's all of gsk's available supply
it means the us will have more than one
million total treatment courses through
the end of march
and we're using every tool at our
disposal including the defense
production act to accelerate delivery of
these gsk doses as quickly as possible
lastly we're also in the process of
ordering another half million doses of
asterzenica's preventive therapy from
immunocompromised individuals
the federal government was instrumental
in the research and development of this
product
and our latest order will also bring us
to over one million doses available
through the end of march
bottom line we've acted aggressively to
support and secure a diverse portfolio
of covid treatments
and as a result our nation's medicine
cabinet has never been more stocked
with four million effective treatments
available in january alone
with that i'll turn it over to dr falchi
to talk about
each of these treatments and important
research into future antivirals dr
falchi
thank you very much jeff what i'd like
to do over the next few minutes is talk
about what jeff referred to
as the omicron medicine cabinet
first of all before i get on to the
therapy i want to underscore the
importance
that the up-to-date covet-19 vaccination
with boosters prevents severe disease
and keeps you out of the hospital as
underscored by dr olensky i want to
focus now what happens if you do get
sick what are the therapies to prevent
you to get disease progression next
slide
i really want to refer people
to the details of what i'll be saying
over the next few minutes that can be
easily found
in the nih covert 19 treatment
guidelines that are accessible online
very briefly this is the
state-of-the-art guidance for clinicians
for the treatment of patients with
covert 19
and it is a panel which includes
representatives from six government
agencies
with 42 voting members
from 10 professional medical societies
academia and health care systems
we began march 24 2020
the first headline was released in april
2016
who had 44 updates
in which there were 30 million plus page
reviews next slide
so let's look at what we have there
there are two major pillars of
therapeutics one is to target the virus
and i'll get into those individual drugs
in a moment
the other which i won't speak about very
much but just to let you know
that to moderate the immune response and
the inflammatory response with late
disease
by the therapy shown on this slide such
as dexamethasone testilijumab paracetam
let me show you how that goes
when you look at the stages of disease
next slide
as you can see there is a spectrum
from an infected person with no symptoms
to an outpatient with mild symptoms an
inpatient
not requiring oxygen
low flow high flow and then the ultimate
which you obviously like to avoid in all
costs is mechanical ventilation
one targets the virus
early on
with some overlap in the later stage
with moderate moderating the host
response next slide
what we really want to do among several
other things
is to prevent people from progressing to
serious disease
and you do that
by treating people as out patients
thereby reducing the visit to urgent
care setting
to hospitalizations and ultimately
deaths
you reduce the duration of illness
you reduce to some extent infectivity
and transmission
and importantly particularly
as we're dealing with this extraordinary
situation with omicron
you minimize the stress on the health
care system
now the highest priority
as always should be given to patients
with the highest risk
of progression
so let's take a look at that next slide
the prioritization of therapies first
among
omicron for these patients with mild to
moderate disease at high risk the
numbers on the right
show what the clinical trials have shown
is the relative risk of reduction for
hospitalization or death
as you see at the top of the list
is the drug
that jeff mentioned tax libid which
received an eua
five days of oral therapy eighty-nine
percent reduction
satravimab
a single infusion of a monoclonal
antibody that works against omicron
85 percent relative risk reduction
rem death severe is an already approved
drug
it's used off label with a three-day
infusion with a very high level of a
relative risk reduction
and finally malnutrition which is a
five-day oral drug with 30 percent
diminution next slide what about the
prioritization of therapies for
outpatients
among limited resources
now i know this slide has a lot of words
on it you can easily access this if you
want to focus on it in the treatment
guidelines first and foremost the
immunocompromised
individuals who are unvaccinated at high
risk what do we mean by high risk
anyone greater than 75 years old of age
or greater than 65 with a clinical risk
factor
next comes the unvaccinated at increased
risk
namely anyone greater than 65 or in less
than 65 with a clinical risk
and then vaccinated at high risk
or vaccinated at increased risk again
may be difficult to remember quickly but
they're all in the treatment guidelines
next slide
in addition what about the pipeline
where are we going
there are a number of phase two and
phase three trials of potential covet 19
therapies
that are active or pending and you can
go to www.clinicaltrials.gov
to see the status of that there are
selective agents in late state testing
that are antibodies antivirals repurpose
drugs immunomodulators
and anticoagulants next slide
there is a program which we started
early on called the accelerated covert
19 therapeutics interventions and
vaccines
referred to as active which many of you
may be familiar with next slide what
does active do
they have a number of trials six in
number
looking individually at immune
modulators
outpatient monoclonal antibody therapies
inpatient monoclonal antibodies
antithrombotics
big effect trials looking at treatments
for larger clinical trials to identify
promising drugs
and active six
which is looking at repurposed drugs the
drugs that people want to know
what the results are in a good trial
such as philzoxamine ivamectum and fu
and futicazone next slide
finally
what's today's takeaway
first to re-emphasize
up-to-date vaccination is essential
you can go to vaccines.gov you can text
your zip code you can call
but importantly to reiterate what i was
saying the therapies and treatment
guidelines
are available on the website shown here
back to you jeff
thanks dr falchi so before we open it up
to q a a quick personnel update
we've named dr tom inglesby who was
previously director of johns hopkins
center for health security
to lead our federal testing program
dr engelsby is one of the world's
leading infectious disease experts
and is internationally recognized in the
field of public health preparedness
pandemic and emergent effectiveness
effective
infectious disease and prevention of in
response to biological threats sorry tom
we continue to work across multiple
fronts to increase americans access to
testing and we're all very very grateful
for his willingness tom's willingness to
lead these efforts with that let's open
it up for some questions
kevin
thanks jeff um we have time for a few
questions let's go to berkeley lovelace
at nbc news
hi uh thanks for taking my question um
during dr wallensky's opening remarks
she said there was a 40 increase in
deaths over the previous week
does the cdc expect that those cases are
delta related since uh deaths tend to
lack cases and hospitalizations or or
could it be
omicron and just because there's a sheer
a huge number of cases there's going to
be a larger portion of deaths thanks
dr wolinski
yeah that's a really important question
i believe right now that those deaths
are still the lagging deaths from
omicron um we saw i'm sorry from delta
the lacking deaths from the delta wave
we um have seen as you noted um that
death rates are down from omicron of
about 91
um and we will need to follow those
deaths over the next couple of weeks to
see the impact of omicron on mortality
as you note given the sheer number of
cases we may see that deaths um from we
may see deaths from omicron but i
suspect the deaths that we're seeing now
are still from delta
next question please
alison aubry at npr
allison
sorry about that that is my mute button
thanks for taking my question i know
there's a lot of focus on the quality of
masks right now my daughter's elementary
school is handing out m95s does the us
have enough and 95 respirators to go
around if everyone were to start wearing
these high quality masks or would this
put stress on the or shortages needed
for a 95 mask for healthcare workers
so why don't i go first then dr wolinski
if you want to
add anything here one of the first
things we did
when we entered office was to
significantly improve our manufacturing
stock and stockpile of all
ppe
today n95 mass are
widely available and the government has
a strong
stockpile of over 750 million mass for
healthcare workers
and first responders
cdc as dr willinski can speak to
recommends americans wear a well-fitting
mask this can include
multiple layered cloth masks n95s k95s
or other types
right now we're
strongly considering
options to make more high quality masks
available to all americans and we'll
continue to follow the science here the
cdc's in the lead
but this is an act this is an area that
we're actively
exploring dr malinsky
yeah maybe i'll just add that cdc
continues to recommend that any mask is
better than no mask and we do encourage
um all americans to wear a well-fitting
mask to protect themselves and prevent
the spread of covet 19.
and that recommendation is not going to
change so i maybe i'll just note that we
are preparing an update to the
information on our mask website to best
reflect the options that are available
to people as you note and the different
levels of protection different masks
provide and we want to provide americans
the best and most updated information to
choose what mask is going to be right
for them thank you
next question please
go to jeff mason at reuters
uh thanks very much and good morning
jeff could you um
could you expand on what you just said
about uh planning to or looking at more
options to make sure more high quality
math are available to all americans and
can you also give us an update on your
thinking with regard to timing in terms
of asking congress for more money to
to fund the
this effort yeah thanks jeff
you know in terms of the
mask as i said we're
in the process right now of strongly
considering options to make more
high-quality masks available to all
americans
in terms of money we have the money that
we need to fight omicron as the
president has always said we'll do
everything that we need to do to beat
this pandemic and if we do need more
money
at more funding at some point we will
request that money
next question
zeke miller app
thanks for doing this um
uh first um
there's been a lot of conversation the
last few weeks about testing now that uh
starting saturday uh private insurers
are gonna reimburse testing and that the
federal government's testing website's
gonna be uh coming online soon how is
there new federal guidance on how and
when people should be testing themselves
at home
you know it should be you know once a
week should be twice a week should it be
after an exposure should it be just to
go to the grocery store and then
secondly for dr walinski with that uh
that pre-print study about uh omicron
versus delta how does a crime
compared to other sort of seasonal
illnesses flu
uh
the cold other things like that in terms
of mortality and serious
illnesses and how does that change how
the federal government will be thinking
about
omicron and copa 19 as it becomes
endemic
okay well why don't we turn to dr
wilinski on both dr linsky first when
when americans should test
yeah so so simply put americans should
take a test when they have symptoms that
appear to be cova-19 so
fever cough sore throat respiratory
symptoms muscle aches
when they're exposed so five days after
they've been exposed to someone who has
cova-19 and certainly if you're going to
um gather with uh with family if you're
going to a gathering where people are
immunocompromised or aware they're
elderly or where you have um people who
might be unvaccinated or poorly
protected from the vaccine that might be
an opportunity you'd want to test and
then of course for tests to stay in
other protocols um with regard to this
study actually only compared omicron to
delta and not to other respiratory
viruses certainly other respiratory
viruses influenza for example vary the
severity varies by flu season so this
was not a direct comparison of um
omicron versus other respiratory viruses
but what i can say is we are while we're
in this omicron surge we are also
thinking about what this looks like with
um endemic when omicron or code itself
were to become endemic in the united
states following things such as severity
of cases hospital capacity as well thank
you
next question
please let's go to sabrina siddiki wall
street journal
thank you for taking the call um i
wanted to have asked a follow-up about
the school testing
expansion for these tests that you're
making available for k-12 schools can
you clarify would only public schools be
eligible to receive those tests or
private schools as well and can you
offer any other detail on where the
tests are coming from have you already
inked contracts with certain companies
or is that process still ongoing
well let me just step back and say that
you know many schools
have a dedicated supply
of tests um that they secured months ago
thanks to the 10 billion i talked about
my opening comments that the arp the
american rescue plan
gave to schools dedicated for testing
and there is significant lab capacity
in this country
so we're working with schools to take
advantage of the lab capacity that is
open
in the country cdc and
the department of ed are adding
resources to help schools identify
testing providers and implement best
practices and the federal government is
funding and strongly
encouraging these testing programs in
total
the uh 10 million
send out funds will leverage existing
contracting authorities at both hhs and
cdc and this will more than
double the volume of testing
that took place across the nation
last year we'll follow up sabrina with
uh exactly which schools uh qualify for
these additional 10 million tests
next question
cheyenne haslett abc
hi thank you um my question is also on
the
school testing um
we already saw 10 billion dollars go out
to schools for testing and we're still
seeing school closures so i'm wondering
how you expect this 10 million tests to
be different
um specifically how schools how you'll
get schools to use these in an effective
systematic way that keeps them open
uh consistently well schools do have the
resources through the 10 billion dollars
that went out for the american rescue
plan
and these 10 million tests
add to the testing availability for
schools and as i mentioned is double
the testing that was done in the month
of november i think it's important to
put testing in the context of the
overall
school mitigate school strategies to
keep schools open and for that maybe
i'll turn to dr wolinski to overview
uh the best practices for keeping
schools open dr wolinski yeah thank you
jeff i i'd just like to remind people
that we had a pretty robust delta surge
in the fall um and we were able to keep
99 of schools open safely in our
children with in-person learning and i
will just also highlight that that was
before we had pediatric vaccination so
now here we are we have pediatric
vaccination one of the best things that
we can do is get our children and our
teenagers vaccinated and then once we do
so practicing all those layered
mitigation strategies masking we've seen
three and a half times less likely to
have schools have an outbreak if you're
masking in those schools
as well as ventilation and then of
course test distress strategies which
these resources will really be helpful
for
next question
a couple more questions let's go to
joyce frieden at medpage today
uh hi yeah thanks for taking my question
um
during a senate hearing yesterday um
janet woodcock mentioned that it was
going to be difficult for people to get
their head around the idea
that most of us
are going to get omicron
so i wondered what the
administration's
thinking on that is that are in fact
most of us going to get omicron
and whether they think that's going to
happen
now during this current wave or is that
more looking at as it becomes endemic
dr
fauci yeah thank you very much for that
question
what uh dr woodcock was referring to
when she said most of us will ultimately
get uh omicron is not that
most of us were ultimately going to get
sick with omicron remember she was
talking about in the data that we all
showed
about the extraordinary effect and
dichotomy
between people who get omicron who get
uh vaccinated and boosted how well they
are protected against hospitalization
and death and even with omicron
it appears as the data that dr walensky
just showed today from the kaiser
permanente study that it is going to be
a less severe particularly in those who
are vaccinated and boosted so if we're
going to look ahead
at what happens when this peaks and it
ultimately goes down as i've said on
previous
pressers here from the white house
that we're not going to eradicate this
we've only done that with smallpox we're
not going to eliminate that that only
happens with massive vaccination
programs like we did with measles and
with vaccines but we ultimately will
control it
and if you control it in a way it's at a
such a low level and people are
vaccinated and boosted
sooner or later as we begin to live with
it what she was referring to is that
virtually everybody is going to wind up
getting exposed and likely get infected
but if you're vaccinated and if you're
boosted the chances of you getting sick
are very very low that's what she was
referring to
next question please
last question let's go to ouija cbs
thanks a lot kevin and thank you for
having this call um i first have a
follow-up for dr wolinski because you
said that you do not intend to change
the masking guidance but we also know
now that some masks provide better
protection than others so
why isn't it the case that the best mask
for every american is the mask that
offers the most protection
and then secondly do we have enough data
about the reinfection of omicron
i think there's a sense out there that
if i catch it i'm not going to get it
again is that true or do we not know yet
thank you
dr wolinski do you want to handle the
first question maybe dr falchi the
second
perfect yeah so thank you for that
question um we are updating the
information on our mask website to
provide um information to the public
it's in need of updating right now what
i will say is the best mask that you can
that you wear is the one that you will
wear and the one you can keep on all day
long that you can tolerate in public
indoor settings and tolerate where you
need to wear it
we will provide information on improved
filtration and that occurs with other
masks such as n95s and information that
the public needs about how to make a
choice of which mask is the right one
for them um but most importantly we want
to highlight that the the best mask for
you is the one that you can wear um
comfortably thank you dr fauci
yeah thank you for that question there's
both sides of the coin to that we know
from the south african data that if
you've been previously infected for
example with delta or with beta that you
have a much higher chance of getting
reinfected with omicron than you do with
others that's that side of the coin but
the question you asked is if you get
omicron and recover what is the chances
of getting reinfected with omicron we
don't have enough data at this point to
really give you any firm indication of
that but as we get more and more
experience and as we follow cohorts
we'll be able to have that information
for you
well thank you everybody we look forward
to the next briefing
you